Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Quand on me demande de rêver l’avenir,
je ne peux m’empêcher
de voir un cauchemar.
Crise climatique, infertilité des terres,
insécurité alimentaire.
Un charmant cocktail qui ne me donne pas
franchement envie de m'y projeter.
Et si nous acceptions que cet avenir sera
certainement composé de ce scénario,
une situation à laquelle
on doit s’adapter.
Mais alors là, comment on s’y prépare
à vivre ça au quotidien ?
Comment on fera avec nos 10 milliards
d’êtres humains dans 30 ans
suivant le système actuel ?
Dix milliards d’êtres humains,
ça restera 0,01%
des êtres vivants sur Terre.
À côté, les végétaux, c’est plus de 82%.
Et pourtant, chez eux,
le nombre n’est pas un problème.
Et ça, ça me donne espoir.
Savoir que d’innombrables êtres vivants
sont apparus bien avant nous
et ont su s’adapter,
souvent par association avec d’autres.
Impossible pour nous ?
Je ne crois pas.
Je suis Manon Poncato,
j’ai un master en biotechnologie,
j’accompagne aujourd’hui des projets
de réintégration du vivant en ville.
Je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
c'est important pour moi.
Beaucoup d'espèces font partie de notre
quotidien et pourtant on les connaît peu.
Mais pourquoi les connaît-on si peu ?
Ça me dérange de connaître plus de jingles
de pub que de chants d’oiseaux !
Pourtant eux aussi,
je les entends tous les jours.
Être coupée de la nature,
je le vis particulièrement en ville
où entretien a longtemps rimé
avec retrait de tout ce qui dépasse.
(Inspire)
Un de mes déclics a justement été
de regarder une vidéo d’un botaniste
qui nommait à la craie les plantes
au sol à Toulouse.
Il disait qu’on respecte et qu’on protège
mieux ce que l’on connaît.
C’était Boris Presseq sur le média Brut.
Il symbolisait alors humblement pour moi
cette envie de mieux connaître
le vivant qui nous entoure.
Car connaître, c'est la première
étape pour coopérer.
Aujourd’hui, nous pouvons nous permettre
d’accueillir le sauvage,
de créer du lien avec
d’autres espèces vivantes,
sans pour autant être vulnérable.
Mieux les comprendre.
S'en inspirer.
Répondre à leurs besoins.
Et sans pour autant diminuer notre niveau
de vie, voire en l’améliorant.
En ce sens,
l’Union européenne, en 2015,
a créé le concept
de solutions fondées sur la nature.
Il est utilisé par celles et ceux qui,
comme moi, s’interrogent
sur les liens d’entraide
au sein du vivant,
mais plus largement que l’humain.
Un exemple simple peut être de garder
des arbres sur les places publiques
pour rester au frais l’été plutôt
que d’installer des brumisateurs.
Car les arbres, en plus de l’ombre,
ont ce qu’on appelle un mécanisme
d’évapo-transpiration
qui peut permettre de diminuer
la température ressentie de quatre degrés.
Donc il est important de s'intéresser
sincèrement aux autres espèces.
Et je ne parle pas de l’exploitation
de ces espèces,
ni même d’une inspiration
purement technique,
mais bien de leur vivant,
de tous ces mécanismes
qui agissent en elles,
entre elles et avec nous.
Depuis que j’ai découvert ce concept
pendant mes études,
je me suis passionnée pour ces trésors
et j’ai envie de les voir partout.
J’ai écrit un mémoire là-dessus.
À la base, je voulais documenter
l’utilisation de ces techniques en ville -
donc là où elles manquent le plus -
mais avec mes lectures,
j’ai découvert l’importance vitale
de les réintégrer rapidement
dans nos sociétés
minéralisées, aseptisées.
Grâce à cette recherche, j’ai été
embauchée dans une entreprise
pour créer de toutes pièces un service
de dépollution des sols en ville
grâce à des plantes.
Une solution fondée sur la nature
appelée phytoremédiation.
Avec l’équipe, on a cherché ces plantes,
dans les herbiers, sur les friches,
sur les sites miniers.
On a réuni toutes les publications
scientifiques qu'on trouvait à leur sujet.
On a analysé les sols pour savoir
de quoi elles avaient besoin
et on a planté, planté, planté.
(Inspire)
Je travaille avec des plantes
qui sont des super-héroïnes.
Elles traitent et révèlent l’invisible
sous nos pieds.
Le cresson, par exemple,
se colore et se flétrit au contact
d’une terre déséquilibrée.
On appelle ça un bio-indicateur.
Quel plaisir c’est pour moi
de travailler avec ces plantes,
de faire des réunions dans les jardins,
de discuter avec des personnes qui m’en
apprennent chaque jour un peu plus,
et bien sûr, de les aider dans
leur démarche de dépollution des sols.
Parmi ces personnes, un groupe d’habitants
qui m’a donné à voir dix ans de suivi
de cette technique
dans leur jardin partagé.
Ensemble, on a fait le bilan.
Et on a effectivement observé
la dépollution du sol grâce à une fougère.
Donc oui, c’est possible que
les techniques naturelles nous aident.
Mais oui, ça prend du temps,
le temps du végétal
et c’est bien pour ça
qu’on doit s’y mettre maintenant,
reconsidérer notre rapport à l’efficacité
et voir plus grand que nous.
Le vivant,
non seulement ça marche,
mais en plus, ce n’est que le début.
Regardez pour la robotique,
ça a commencé au début du 20ᵉ siècle.
Vous voyez où on en est aujourd’hui ?
La phytoremédiation à côté
n’est connue que depuis les années 90.
Alors imaginez à la fin du 21ᵉ siècle,
si on y met autant de moyens.
Si aujourd'hui on fait le choix de
l'écologie, qu'on y met autant d'énergie,
autant de financements,
je suis persuadée que les villes de demain
n’auront plus le même visage.
Accueillir la biodiversité contribuerait
au progrès de notre humanité.
Et pour moi, c'est un tournant au moins
aussi important que celui du numérique.
Mais revenons à mon aventure.
Deux années et quelques kilos
de semences plantées plus tard,
c’est moi qui me retrouve sur Brut.
expliquant le principe de phytoremédiation
appliqué à un projet
d’agriculture urbaine à Lyon.
La vidéo fait le buzz.
Plus d’un demi-million de vues.
Des centaines de personnes
et d’organisations nous contactent ensuite
pour savoir si leur sol est pollué
et comment agir dessus avec des plantes.
Le pari est gagné.
Ce service est utile.
Je l’ai vécu moi-même.
Une entreprise peut se monter
sur l’application
de solutions fondées sur la nature
et rémunérer des personnes
pour régénérer les écosystèmes.
La phytoremédiation va être appliquée
de plus en plus.
On l’a enfin sortie
des bouquins scientifiques
et on l’a mise à disposition
du plus grand nombre.
On pourrait penser que
ce sujet est technique
et ne concerne pas grand-monde,
mais, j’espère que vous l’avez compris,
nous sommes tous et toutes concernés.
D’ailleurs les collectivités
l’ont bien compris
et accompagnent déjà
sur le plan technique et financier
des démarches
en faveur de la nature en ville.
J’en découvre chaque jour,
des nouveaux exemples comme ça.
Saviez-vous que la ville de Lyon
a des vergers publics
dans chaque arrondissement aujourd’hui ?
Et connaissez-vous ce que sont
les projets alimentaires territoriaux ?
Ce sont des projets qui consistent
à alimenter en bio et local
des milliers d’enfants
à la cantine chaque jour.
Moi, ça me donnerait envie
d’y retourner, à la cantine.
Et en plus, de nombreuses
entreprises se sont créées,
surtout ces dix dernières années,
pour proposer des produits et des services
pour aider dans ces démarches.
Donc on s'active.
Vous voyez, c’est en cours,
mais il y a encore du travail.
En plus des collectivités, les industriels
doivent appliquer ces techniques
à grande échelle.
Et pour moi, passer à grande échelle,
ça voudrait dire que
tous les enfants aient le choix
de manger bio et en circuit court
à la cantine chaque jour.
Ça voudrait dire que toutes les familles,
peu importe leurs revenus,
aient l’accès, à pied, à un espace vert
gratuit à côté de chez elles.
Et ça voudrait dire que
ces espaces verts soient résilients,
qu’on permette aux arbres de se soutenir
et de communiquer entre eux,
comme l’ont montré de nombreuses études.
Qu'on les sorte de la solitude.
Et nous, citoyens,
comment peut-on participer ?
L’idée que je vais vous partager ici,
c’est pour sortir du victimisme,
de la culpabilisation.
Du : «on ne peut rien y faire»,
ou : «c’est comme ça.»
Mais bien de prendre l’héritage
du passé comme un sujet à traiter
parmi tant d'autres.
On comprend, on répare
et on fait autrement.
Il y a des projets qui existent
et qui ont du sens pour moi.
Je vais vous parler d’un,
que j’aime tout particulièrement
parce qu’on peut tous
et toutes y participer.
Ça permet de réguler les invasifs,
comme les moustiques.
Et je suis persuadée que
ça peut nous faire de belles villes :
les corridors écologiques.
Les corridors écologiques relient
par des végétaux, de la terre, de l’eau,
des espaces naturels
en passant par la ville.
Donc pour visualiser des corridors,
imaginez la ville comme un corps humain.
Les espaces naturels sont
les organes respiratoires
et il est nécessaire de les connecter
entre eux par des ramifications multiples
qui vont donc permettre
à la ville de respirer.
Quand vous commencerez à faire
attention à ces continuités,
vous allez les voir partout arrêtées
par du goudron, une route, des bâtiments.
Et c'est là que nous pouvons agir.
L'enjeu est de recréer ces continuités.
Déjà pour ça, il y a les jardins partagés
que tout le monde peut rejoindre.
Rien qu’à Lyon, le PASSE-jardins,
en enregistre des centaines
et il y en a encore beaucoup
d’autres à créer.
Allez voir vos voisins,
réfléchissez ensemble
à ce que vous avez envie de faire.
On ne change pas la ville
seul dans son coin.
Le changement a besoin
d’une volonté collective.
Et après, que ce soit planter des arbres,
retirer du goudron, végétaliser un toit,
faire grimper des végétaux
sur un bâtiment, peu importe.
Faites respirer la ville.
Car les villes telles
qu’elles sont encore aujourd’hui
confondent spontanéité et moindre effort,
liberté et individualisme.
Lions-nous.
Réintégrons le vivant.
Anticipons, prenons les devants.
Considérons la régénération
des écosystèmes
comme un devoir d’intérêt général
soutenu par les instances publiques
et valorisées par les acteurs économiques.
Bientôt,
et j’y crois,
on trouvera ça normal de se balader
en ville, émerveillé par tout ce vivant,
et de faire son goûter à même les arbres.
Ce serait ça, une ville nourricière.
Et même à Blois,
on pourrait imaginer une ville
où on verrait à peine les constructions
sous la végétation
qui s’approprie l’espace,
mais où rien pour autant
ne serait à l’abandon.
Tout semblerait pratique, fonctionnel
et en symbiose avec la nature.
Les bâtiments ne seraient
alors plus des obstacles,
mais bien des tuteurs pour soutenir
et orienter toute cette végétation.
La ville nourricière nourrit
en partie le corps,
mais surtout l’esprit
et le lien avec les autres.
Avec elle, nous saurons nous adapter.
Et le mieux pour moi dans cette ambition,
c’est de me dire que
nous ne sommes pas seuls.
De nombreuses espèces
sont prêtes à nous aider,
si tant est qu’on leur laisse
un petit peu de place.
Nous aider
à ce que le cauchemar s’estompe
et laisse place au rêve.
Donc quand vous verrez une petite plante,
frêle mais vaillante,
dans un interstice de pavés,
pensez à ce que je viens de vous dire
et rappelez-vous qu’en fait, ce n’est
pas nous qui défendons la nature,
c’est la nature qui se défend
à travers nous.
Alors, on s’y met ?
(Applaudissements)